your character uh gene rayne struggles
with like wanting to be the perfect
mother
friend cook worker which is like super
pandemic friendly
it sounds you know like a lot of us
moms who are highly invested was this a
good
opportunity for catharsis and
relatability are you like her or are you
different
i mean i i would say it's so funny
because my daughter watched it she went
mom
she's just like you um because they see
us in a way see
ourselves i know i'm like really no uh
yeah
you know i i think i i am like jean in
the sense that like
my motherhood really defines me i mean
i've been an actor forever and um
but you know and i have my own career
and my own life and i always have but
like
mom is my like title that's the thing i
think about in the morning it's the
thing i think about when i go to sleep
and i
i just think that i mean i relate to
jean because her kids are gone and i
think that it's such a weird
thing that happens that if you do your
job right as a mom your kids leave you
yeah um so but also i i love that jeans
just try
so hard like i try hard you know i am
such i try so hard i really do and my
kids are still luckily at that age where
they
indulge me um but i
did read that you and kevin walk around
the house
naked since you've been empty nesters is
this true because i do it too
i mean more naked than usual but like i
wouldn't say we're naked all the time
by any stretch i just got so excited
because i was like
when my kids go to their dads and no
one's in the house i fully walk around
naked yeah and it's
like i've slept naked and i'll just go
out and get my morning
tea exactly no that's true because i can
and it's so exciting what a freedom um
well in honor of your new show
call your mother we have a vff who says
her mom is a huge fan of
yours and we were wondering if we could
give her a
call of course are you up to call her of
course
okay ari where are you
hi it is so exciting to be here drew
you're amazing i love you so much kyra
such a huge fan
oh thanks i heard your mom is a crazy
uber fan is this true
she is and she is not on facebook that
much but she's
a super fan in your facebook fan group
um so i'm really excited to surprise her
okay so we told your mom linda that
she's gonna be meeting with an executive
producer from the show today for a
mother's day special
so we're gonna surprise her are you
ready uh
i'm ready okay linda are you there
oh hi linda
[Music]
hi hi it's kira
oh my god this is the greatest day of my
life
your face your your exuberance is like
filling my heart you have no idea did
you hear what she said she loves your
hair
i said the same thing linda i love your
hair linda
black hair
okay linda is it true that you watched
every episode of the closer
oh everyone everyone kiera let me
promise you everyone oh
yes that makes me feel so happy
well linda i just want to thank you for
coming here and bursting with light and
energy
she deserves nothing less and man you
delivered you
really did it's so nice to meet you
and your lovely daughter thank you
happy mother's day yes happy mother's
day and
thank you linda and ari so much well
kyra
i'm so honored that you came here thank
you i love your
mothering and parenting um we've all
loved watching you and kevin
bacon be out in the world representing
love
you know and longevity and
just coolness you guys are so cool
that's so funny i think i'm so uncool i
love it well thank you kyra for joining
us today call your mother heirs tonight
and every wednesday at 9 30 8 30 central
on
abc it's fantastic